I'm at Harvard at an executive program
for three weeks and it is the face of
the class where everybody's open
dialogue they're talking with each other
there's 144 of us from 60 plus countries
and one of the guys says you know I have
a business we had 25 percent of market
share we were doing great but a new
business has come up and it's taken six
percent away from me and it's really
become a payment about for us it's
annoying how how do you guys handle this
from different parts of the country
one of the guys he says uh well it's
very easy who's running for office and
he says what do you mean he says well in
Brazil what we do is you just look for
who's running for office that can help
pass some laws you give them some cash
and when they go in if they need a favor
they're going to pay their favor for you
create new regulations to her and the
way he said it he didn't have a smile on
his face he said it as if it's written
in business books that this is how you
put out a small business